I'm not Wilson and I'm the
representative for the District of
Columbia and the National Geographic you
I'm standing in front of the National
Geographic headquarters right now 17
state where the national competition
will be held
Here I am at the Embassy of Kuwait and
Bahrain if someone gave me a free ticket
to go anywhere
I would go to Italy to see them
and to see vatican city and tennis and
all the other
i'm standing in front of the chinese
embassy right now it's one of the larger
young see a singapore
you
Here I am embassy of Bangladesh capital
Bangladesh's daughters the embassy of
Donna
a Pakistani embassy the Embassy of the
United Arab Emirates
mca slovakia
and the sea of Austria
and the simulator
this is the statue of Winston Churchill
it's half on the british embassy
property and have in the district
u.s. National Observatory it's worth
Vice President Joe
official time
it states
this is the National Cathedral and it's
where many of the presidents
for who
if you order come to my town Washington
DC you should check out a bunch of the
monuments like the Washington Monument
like in order to see as many of the
Smithsonian
you